Vladimir Poutine conduisant lui-même une
voiture sur le pont de Crimée
partiellement détruit en octobre dans
des circonstances encore non élucidés
les images tournent en boucle dans les
médias russes à ses côtés sur le siège
passager le vice premier ministre Marat
dresse un rapport au chef du Kremlin sur
la progression des travaux de réparation
du pont Moscou avait attribué sa
destruction à un acte terroriste des
Ukrainiens c'est la première visite de
vladima Poutine dans la péninsule
annexée depuis le début de l'offensive
contre l'Ukraine une offensive que le
Kremlin est bien déterminé à poursuivre
et ce malgré l'entrée en vigueur des
dernières sanctions occidentales le prix
du pétrole des armées plafonnées à
l'achat par l'Europe à 60 dollars le
baril une mesure qui n'aura pas d'impact
sur la Russie à sur MOS